.
In this demo I will hit a set of
Polynomials, and I hope this will give you
Feeling confident enough when you have to hit it
Yourself
Let's start with a simple issue
Suppose we want to multiply 2x × (4x - 5)
Well, here we will use
Directly Distribute
In fact, when we multiply all these polynomials
All we use is
The distribution property is several times
But let's use the distribution function here
This is equal to (2x × 4x) + (2x × -5)
Or you can say -5 × 2x
So we will say, -5 × 2x
All I did was distribute the 2x
The first phrase will be equal - we can strike
Transactions -
Remember that 2x x 4x is equivalent - you can
Reorder the multiplication process--
This is equivalent to 2 × 4 × x × x
Equivalent to 8 × x ^ 2
Remember that when you hit x ^ x ^ x ^ 1, we collect the bases
I mean, you know that x x x = x ^ 2
If the first phrase equals 8x ^ 2
The second term, -5 × 2 = -10x
Not bad
Let's do one more solution
Suppose we have 9x ^ 3 × (3x ^ 2
- 2x + 7)
If again, we will use
Distribution property here
We will hit 9x ^ 3 each
These words
If 9x ^ 3 × 3x ^ 2
I will type it this time
On the following issues, we will begin to do so
It's mentally
If this equals 9x ^ 3 × 3x ^ 2
And then we have - let me write it down
Method - - (2x × 9x ^ 3) and then + (7 ×
9x ^ 3)
At times I have written 9x ^ 3 first, and at some times have
We wrote later because I wanted to put these
Negative sign here
But this does not change the order in which
We hit it
So how much is this first sentence?
9 × 3 = 27, × x ^ - we can gather
The basics, we learned that in studying the properties of the foundations -
This is x ^ 5, and 2 × 9 = 18x ^
- We have x ^ 1 and x ^ 3--
x ^ 4
+ 7 × 9 = 63x ^ 3
If we've ended up to
Multi-border Class V
Now let's make one solution that contains two double-border expressions
I will explain to you what I mean quickly
You will see this
Much in algebra
So let's assume that we have (x-3) (x + 2)
In fact I want to make it clear to you that all we do here is
Use the Distribute property
So let me put it this way: x (x + 2)
So let's pretend that this is just a large number
It is
As you know, if we have a set of x, this would be a number here
So let's distribute these to each of these variables
This is equal to x (3) × x written in green, + (x
- 3 × × 2 written in green
All we did was distribute the x - 3
This is a distribution property
Remember, if I have a x (x + 2), what should I do?
Equal?
This will equal (a × x) + (a × 2)
If here, you can see it when X - 3 is tied
a, we distribute it
Now we will use the distribution feature again
In this case, we will now distribute x on
x - 3
We will distribute 2 on x - 3
You may have been used to seeing the x on the other side, however
In any way, you will hit
If this equals - I will continue coloring -
This is equal to (x x x) - (3 x x) + (x x 2)
- I bear the trouble of this until it continues
They are painted for you
I think this will help you - - (3 × 2)
All I did was distribute x and divide 2
And soon you will get used to this
We can do one step
You actually hit every word here
With each subsequent phrase, we will find faster ways
In the future to do this
But I really want to show you the idea here
How much is this?
This equals x ^ 2
This is equal to -3x
This is equal to 2x
And then this is equal to -6
Thus the output is x ^ 2 - 3 of something
+ 2 of something, and this equals 1 of that thing
- x - 6
We hit them
Now before we continue and solve another issue, I want to
I explained to you that you can do it mentally
You do not have to go through all these steps
Just wanted to explain to you that this is about
Distributive property
The faster way to do this, if we have (x - 3) (x
+ 2), you will actually hit each phrase
Here in each of these statements
So you'll say, x these x x ones
And you get x ^ 2
Then we have x these x 2 ones, this is equal to 2x
Then we have -3x, this is equal to -3x
Then -3 × 2
Which equals -6
So when you hit again you'll get x ^ 2
- x - 6
This needs some practice to
You get really used to it
Now the other thing I want to do - and the main thing is
It's exactly the same way - but I'll hit
A double-edged phrase with three words, that's what
Many people find him tired
But we will see, if you remain calm
This is not so bad
(3x + 2) (9x - 6x + 4)
Now, how to use the same method we used in
Previous view
We can take (3x + 2) and distribute it on
Each of these three statements, multiply 3x + 2 each
Of these terms, and then distribute
Both of these statements are on 3x + 2
It will take a long time, and in fact, you will not hit it
this way
But you will get the same answer we will get
When you have multiple integers larger than these, the simplest way is that
I can think of it to hit, how to do it
By multiplying the long numbers
We'll write it that way
9x ^ 2 - 6x + 4
We will multiply it by 3x + 2
What I imagine is, when you hit normal numbers
You have the status of the individual, the status of dozens
And the status of hundreds
Here, we have the status of constants
First Class, Second Class
And the third degree status, if any
In fact, it's present in this show
So you have to put things in their proper place
let's do it
We will start from here, beating exactly as
We do the traditional beating
2 x 4 = 8
And go to the status of the individual, or the status of the constants
2 × 6, 2 × 6 = - or
2 x -6x = -12x
We will put + here
This was = 8
2 × 9x ^ 2 = 18x ^ 2, if we put this in
Status x ^ 2
Now let's move on to part 3x
I will do it in purple, and as you can see it is different
3x × 4 = 12x, positive 12x
3x × -6x, how much is this?
x x x = x ^ 2, so
Will go here
And 3 × -6 = -18
Finally, we have 3x × 9x, x x x ^ 2
= x ^ 3
3 × 9 = 27
You typed it in x ^ 3
Again, you will collect
Similar phrases, get 8
There is no other constant, if we have only 8
-12x + 12x, these are deleted
18x ^ 2 - 18x ^ 2 are deleted, so we have left
Here is 27x ^ 3
If this equals 27x ^ 3 + 8
We're done
You can use this technique to hit a triangular border
With double-edged words, a trigeminal term × a trigonometric term, or in fact
As you know, you can get five phrases here
A phrase of the fifth grade × a term of the fifth degree
This will always succeed as long as you keep stuff in
Her proper stature